[Narrator] Everyone on the internet
was in love with "The Grinch,"
When asked if they enjoyed it
they'd say "Yes" in a pinch;
Jim Carrey's so funny
and Ron Howard's a gem,
and this holiday classic
is perfect for them.
Yes, the film seemed to make
so many people happy,
but, the Grump [dramatic musical cue]
of Channel Awesome
found it all crappy.
He hated "The Grinch";
every part of the movie
Please don't ask why,
we're not sure how this could be.
It could be that his head
wasn't screwed on just right.
Or perhaps it could be
that his shoes were too tight.
[Critic] Why would shoes affect
how I feel about something? I...don't get that
[Narrator]  But the most likely reason of all,
I should think,
Is the Grump thought his brain
was two sizes too big.
But whatever the reason
you might want to pick
the Grump spent his time
HATING the flick.
Staring down
with a grumpy Grump frown,
he never got what pleased
all the people in town.
"Can't they see," said the Grump
"That the remake is crap?
I'd rather get my nuts caught in a Lorax trap!"
"P.S. That's gotta suck too."
[Critic] The jokes are atrocious,
the lines make me weepy
They scare up the Grinch
when the WHOs are more creepy!
The original's a classic;
no fixing required
Whoever said this needs an update
is a big fat f*ck liar!
Pop cultural references don't make a film work,
Just makes you look like a big, dumb, lazy-ass jerk!
On top of that,
who the hell made Dr. Seuss PG?
PG? Oh, I see!
Seuss was never child-friendly!
[Narrator] And the more the Grump thought
how this movie could stink,
The more the Grump thought,
"I must stop this whole thing!"
Why for 11 damn years I've put up with it now,
I must stop Christmas from sucking!
...But how?
[Narrator]
And then the Grump got an idea
An awful idea
The Grump got a wonderful, awful idea.
"I know what to do," the Grump said sitting tall,
"If I can't enjoy it, I'll ruin it for them all!"
A critique of this stinker is just what they need,
I'll tell them the truth: my words must take heed!
So come on, ya pansies,
Let the bashing begin!
Stop smoking that Who-Hash
And let us dive in.
[Critic continues]
So this world, we discover,
Takes place on a flake.
[smack] [yell of pain]
Trust me. I did 'em a favor for God's sake.
We see the Whos in Whoville
are merry and bright,
Many of them you'll be seeing
in your nightmares tonight.
Seriously. These Whos
are freaky as hell.
Were their mothers all pregnant
when they fell down that well?
[Cindy] Dad?
[Lou] Yeah?
[Cindy] Doesn't this seem like a bit much?
[Lou] This is what Christmas is all about!
[Critic] But we see our main innocent
And of course her dad too.
This is Cindy Lou Who,
Who is no more than two.
...Well, but we'll give them a little leeway.
[Cindy] Everyone getting all kerbobbled.
Doesn't this seem... superfluous?
[Critic] Good, God, kid.
Did someone put your hair in a blender?
It looks like the penis 'do
from the film Last Airbender.
[Grinch] I guess I could use a little... social interaction.
[Critic] We then see the Grinch:
the epitome of cruel.
And yes, to be fair,
that makeup is pretty cool.
He looks just like the Grinch,
despite the film's flaws.
But hey, could be worse,
they could have given him cat claws.
[Grinch] I merely noticed that you're
improperly packaged, my dear.
[ripping paper] Graah!
[Critic] So, as you'd guessed,
he hates Christmas to a T.
And so would I if lived
in this town constantly!
For Whoville looks dirty,
and kind of polluted
There's smog everywhere
and the colors are muted.
The wide angle makes things
look strangely intense,
And is it me, or did someone
rub Vaseline on the lens?
[Man] What happened to you?
[Teens] It was the Grinch!
[Screaming tires screeching, honking, crashes]
[Critic] And the constant camera movement
has gotta be the worst.
There's more Dutch angles here
than in "Battlefield Earth"!
This doesn't look magical; it's ugly and henious!
This isn't Christmastime,
it's "Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas"!
But, at least we know the Whos have Christmas Spirit in check
[Betty] Well I'd blow every fuse
if I tried to keep up with you, Martha May!"
[Boom! thunk thunk thunk thunk]
[Critic] Up! No, strike that, they're as phony as Glenn Beck.
[Martha] Isn't this antique ~darling?
[Critic] For ya see, these Whos are competitive
and beyond materialistic.
A town that just loves the spirit?
Pfft! I guess that was unrealistic!
For these whos are corrupted
and commercal to the max,
But don't worry, it's just a story arc
written by talentless hacks.
[Martha] Well goodnight Betty!
[Critic] And geesh, is it me
or are the decorations really bright?
[Woman] Is your house on fire, Clark?
[Clark] No, those are ...Christmas lights.
♪ [Cindy] Where are you, Christmas? ♪
[Critic] Ugh! [slams table] Really?
We're letting the brat sing here?
It sounds like something
that came out of Charlotte Church's rear!
♪ [Cindy Lou]
My world is changing ♪
♪ I'm rearranging ♪
[Critic] Now don't get me wrong,
I'm sure she's trying her best
But we need this song
like we needed one in "Polar Express".
It's pointless, unneeded,
and doesn't sound good.
♪ [Grinch] Be it ever so ... heinous ♪
[Critic] Aaand speaking of things
that should be avoided if they could,
♪[Grinch] La ta ta, Ya ha hee, Na taa ta ta ta ♪
[Critic] [Sigh] I give Carey credit;
this role can't be easy:
To act in green latex
is probably not breezy
[Grinch] Hate, hate hate hate, *double* hate
... LOATHE ENTIRELY
[Critic] But GOD is he annoying!
I'm sorry but it's true!
Is there a law to how much mugging
a single person can do?
[Grinch] What if it's a cash bar?
How dare they.
All right, I'll go.
But I'll be fashionably late!
[Critic] [sigh] Just because you can make faces
doesn't mean that you should.
Can't you once say a line
like a normal person would?!
[Grinch growling and mumbling]
[Critic] [sigh] Didn't you take anything
from the great Boris Karloff?
You sound like Sean Connery
if his nostrils just fell off!
[Grinch] Those Whos are hard to frighten, Max!
But, we did our worst. And that's all that matters."
[Connery] Only on account of villainy
[Critic] Little Cindy Lou wants to find out about him
(If I was her I'd avoid him
at every single whim)
[Cindy] Where did he come from?
[Woman] Oh! Well, [laugh] he came the way all new babies come.
Adrift from the sky in their own pumbercellas
[Baby Grinch cries out as he lands]
[Critic] So we see the Grinch
as a small little baby
...That or perhaps
a young Gary Busey baby
As he grows up even older
and we see school's at hand
He looks like Gizmo if he was thrown in the washer
with a green crayon.
[Martha] Oh, I hardly remember him;
I didn't have time to socialize
I was far too busy with my ... studies.
[Critic] We see a girl who likes him.
Guess she ...has a thing for green too
(If you think that's weird,
I know a chick who has a thing for blue)
[Kid] You don't have a chance with her;
You're 8 years old and you have a beard!
So the Grinch was made fun of
for being so damn hairy
(Boy, who'da thought the guy from Passions
would be more subtle than Jim Carrey?)
[Grinch] What a lovely family heirloom!
[Critic] So he makes her a gift
out of all that he's saved
But then he thinks that maybe
he should give himself a shave.
So he goes ahead and shaves his chin
and leaves a couple nicks
And... for some reason it gets the class
all laughing at him like hicks.
[Laughter]
[Grinch] Stupid ribbons!
[crash]
[Critic] Is it me or are the Whos
just who-rible creatures?
They show us the true meaning of Christmas
in this feature?
Even the teacher is laughing!
Dude, what's up with that?!
It's not that funny, lady!
She's as contrived as those brats.
[Grinch] I hate Christmas!
I hate it!
[Movie Narrator] So whatever the reason;
his heart, or his shoes.
He stood outside his cave, hating the whos.
[Critic] Wait a minute! Whatever reason...
Dude, are you high?!
They just told you the reason
you dumb stupid guy!
It's because he was mocked
All the way from the start
What?! Did you just
fall asleep at that part?
So they look for a ringleader:
A Cheermeister they say,
To take on the role
Just before Christmas day.
[Cindy] The Cheermeister is the one
who deserves a back slap or a toast.
And it goes to the soul at Christmas
who needs it most.
And I believe that soul is the Grinch!
[cheering and clapping]
[Critic] So Cindy tells the Grinch
in his Grincy Grinch-lair
Dude, do her parents
ever accompany her anywhere?
[Grinch] How dare you enter the Grinch's Lair?!
The impudence! The *audacity*!
The unmitigated *gall*!
Another unmistakable sign of the heebie-jeeb-eh-ies!
Now. You're. *doomed*!
[Critic] [sighs]
So if you're a strange person
for one reason or another
Who likes to watch men
act like Snarf's deformed brother,
Then this scene's for you!
I'm so filled with glee.
Now please, never make
eye contact with me.
[Grinch] WHAT DO YOU WANT?!?
[Cindy] I came to invite you
to be holiday Cheermeister!
[Critic] So the Grinch heads on down;
He'll be glad that he did!
Because this scene happens!
[crash] [Martha gasps] Oh!
[Critic] You know, for kids! :D
So they force him to party
and have a good time,
Though one certain present
starts to eat at his mind.
A razor, it appears
to have dampened his cheer,
...It didn't make sense then
aand it ...really doesn't here.
[Grinch] This whole Christmas season is ...
stupid, stupid, stupid!
[woman gasps]
[Grinch] Mistletoe
Now pucker up and kiss it, Whoville!
[Nyoinoingoing!]
[Critic] Doctor Seuss would be proud!
This is what he intended:
Mistletoe butts,
for Mom to get offended!
And Jim Carrey's range
once again is in stock,
Can you believe he used to talk from his ass?
I'm shocked!
[flame noise]
So the Grinch goes crazy
and starts attacking the folks
[Grinch] Taxi! [taxi driving past]
It's because I'm green, isn't it?!?
[Critic] Ok, *that's* a good joke.
He takes all his antics
and goes all the way!
[explosion]
Aaaah!
[Critic] There's an explosion in the Grinch.
Who directed this, Michael Bay?
[jingling as ornaments fall]
[Mayor] I'm hurt, Lou
[pats shoulder]
I'm hurt, and I don't hurt easily.
[Critic] So he didn't steal Christmas,
more assassinated it,
When we FINALLY get the plot
that the writers have procrastinated.
He wants to steal Christmas
after Santa gets moving,
...Wait...Santa's in this movie?
That's a ...little confusing...
But no matter. He gets his stuff
and starts to head down,
To visit the sleeping Whos
in their quiet little town.
[rocket engine, Grinch yelling, backfiring, dog barking]
[Critic] [sigh] At the risk of sounding
incredibly droll
D'oh! I can't help it!
[Game] Do a barrel roll!
[Grinch laughing]
[Critic] So this stuff is actually
pretty close to the book
[scoffs] Yeah, I know,
someone actually did take a look!
[Cindy] Santa Claus?
What are you doing with our tree?
[Movie Narrator] But you know, that old Grinch
was so smart and so slick,
[Narrator] That thankfully Cindy
was as dumb as a brick.
[Cindy] Santa, what's Christmas really about?
[Grinch]
Vengeance!
...I mean...
presents.
[Movie Narrator] Then he patted her head
and he got her a drink
and he sent her to bed.
[Critic, imitating Grinch] But hey!
She could still have some fun with me!
I'll eat her liver with fava beans,
and a nice Chianti
[mimic's Hannibal Lector's slurping]
[Cindy] Grinch?
[Grinch, shortly]
What!?
[Cindy]
Don't forget the Grinch.
[Critic] Odd, seeing how the Grinch
is someone she knows,
Bit it fooled her in the book,
so I guess we'll let it go.
But here's a scene
I simply cannot let fly,
It's where the Grinch sees the Mayor's house
and needs to drop by.
[Mayor snores]
[Grinch giggles]
[Mayor, mumbling] Martha...
have you ever kissed a man who lost his tonsils twice?
[Grinch, in faltsetto]
No... silly!
[Mayor makes kissing sounds]
[Max whines]
[Grinch in faltsetto]
But it's an experience that I've *always* longed for.
Kiss me, you fool!
[exagerrated kissing/popping sound]
[Max whining]
[Critic] Really film, really?
You had to go there?
The "Arrested Development" guy
kissing a dog's derrière?!
Did your 5 year old decide
to start writing this part?
[squeaky] Kissing dog's anuses haha!
This is high art!
Now...Just to clarify...
This is the Christmas classic you all love?
A dog's ass, a guy's lips
pleasantly shoved?
Have you gone crazy?
Or totally insane?
How can this scene
cause none of you pain?
What the hell would PETA say
for this little canine?
Aw hell, as long as he's not wearing a tanooki suit
it's fine.
So as the film promised,
he steals the holiday
Which puts all the Whos
in alarming dismay.
[Mayor, shouting] Invite the Grinch, destroy Christmas!
You listen to a little, not to be taken seriously,
GIRL.
[Critic] It takes them a while,
five minutes or more
To realize that Christmas
doesn't come from a store.
[Lou] I'm glad he took our presents!
[crowd gasps]
You can't hurt Christmas, Mr. Mayor
Because it isn't about the-the gifts.
Wh-I don't need anything more for Christmas
than this right here: My family
[crowd aww's]
[Critic] Ya know, I kinda like the original
Yeah, I know, big surprise,
But it made sense that they
already knew where Christmas lies.
For nothing could dampen it
and that was uplifting
Here, there's blaming and yelling
before they start shifting.
The message is there
but it doesn't stand as tall.
And if you can't remake it better,
WHY REMAKE IT AT ALL?!
[Grinch] Maybe Christmas...
...perhaps
...means a little bit more.
[thumping and yelling]
[Critic] Wow. Way to ruin
such a touching little scene
Good God, for a moment,
I almost saw subtlety!
[groaning]
[moaning and sobbing]
That's right, keep yelling
make faces like a whore
We lasted the whole movie;
we can take a bit more!
♪[swelling music]♪
[Critic] So... God's in this movie?
...That I didn't know...
Does he say,
[Man] I am the creator
of a television show
[Cindy] Hi, Mr. Grinch!
[Critic] So with a smile from Cindy,
and a ... ... pedo smile from him,
He brings the gifts back
and the town lets him in.
He hands back the presents
and everyone is happy
Only one other thing
could make this ending more sappy!
[Martha] My heart belongs to... someone else
[Grinch]
Hm?
[Critic] The girl, all grown up,
wants to date him now, see?
Because... once you've gone green...
there's... nothing in between...?
So Christmas is as high
as anybody reaches
And the Grinch carved the beast
made from fresh roasted Sneeches.
[Grinch] Who wants the gizzard?!
[Person] I do!
[Grinch] Too late! That'll be mine
[Critic] That's the film
oh my GOD could it be any longer?
I bet you're wondering what I would do
to make it any stronger.
Well...
Maybe you could shorten it
by an hour or two.
And maybe some bright colors,
for a friendlier view.
A more subtle actor
might be anticipated
And hey, you know what else?
Why not make it animated?
Yes, those are the changes
that I would insist.
Oh wait. We don't need to!
IT F**KING EXISTS!
The original was fine,
spend your time watching that
It's better than this horrifying
crap in a hat!
It's downright unbearable
unpleasant, unfunny
Nothing in this movie
seems colorful or sunny!
It's not fun to look at;
it's not fun to watch!
How on earth did this classic
get so God damn botched?
I really hate this movie.
And you know what, so should you!
I'm the Nostalgia Critic.
I remember it so you don't have to.
Ho Ho! [Narrator] Said the Grump,
uploading his hit
[Critic] They're finding right now
that this movie is sh*t!
They're watching right now;
I know just what they'll do!
Their mouths will hang open
for a moment or two,
And then they'll cry the genius
of you know who!
And those are reactions
that I simply must read
[Narrator] He went to the comments
to take a look and see.
But the reactions that he got
didn't seem very sad
If anything, these reactions
seemed rather ...glad!
♪♪ [Fahoo Fores song from original movie]
♪♪
They still loved the movie
from beginning to end
There was no one to anger,
upset or offend
He didn't stop the people from liking it
they loved it!
Somehow or other...
It was still just as beloved.
And the Grump feeling like
he's been horribly conned
Sat puzzling and puzzling
"What the hell's going on?!?"
They like mistletoe butt!
They like boobs being harrassed!
They like seeing a pervert
kiss a dog's ass!
[Narrator] He puzzled and puzzled
till his puzzler was sore
Then the Grump thought of something
he hadn't before!
Just because he hates something
doesn't mean others should
He could share, not force,
his opinion like others would.
For it's all our different outlooks
that makes us people grow
And everyone is different
like every flake of snow
For different points of view
could exist for a reason
To learn about one another
And to make each other decent
[Critic] Naaah, I'm right and they're wrong.
[Narrator] Well.
F*ck you, then.
[Grinch] Now pucker up and kiss it, Whoville! [Nyoinoingoing!]